Hello, Simtan members.  This
is the Chesley Morning Brief, sharing happy investment plans.  Today is Thursday, July 9th. We will
begin Part 1.
Uh, the Korean market was really bad yesterday
.  I will ask Director Wang whether there was any synchronization in the Chinese market as well
.   yes
.  Yesterday, while doing tag coin trading, the Sisu
Manus dropped from 0.5% to 5%.
Heungsung Tag Index surged by 5%
.  The large-scale regular admission
attracted the level of Lee Jeong 6.  If you
analyze by industry, anyway, the utility, real estate,
concept, smoke, industrial materials, and healthcare sectors have
become weak.  As risk stance
fees and interest rates spread, utility
stocks rebounded.  Yangtze River
rice fields rose by +1.5%, Huanning
water fields by +2.6%, and 5% fields
rose by nearly 1%.
Energy-related stocks also rose due to factors such as the surge in the yoga industry
.  Batro Choi Nan rose by 1.4%,
and Used Shinhwa rose by 1.3%.   I
have almost unrealistic expectations about how pretty it will be.  And the Guangdong time limit came up a bit awkwardly
.   The salt
market in Sijong Ucheon rose by 7%, in
Sinyeok by 15%, and in Cheongbu Gwandong City by
5%.  Regarding Dongjae,
the story coming out yesterday is that there is a possibility it could be released at around 9.9 billion in the second quarter, according to
Romer.  So the stock price went up a bit
.  So, we need to take a look at the screen for the actual situation of Unit 2
.  With expectations for the
expansion of high-tech semiconductors and the mass production of AVs for the 4th generation, the
semiconductor sector is expected to be fully covered in the first division
.  Korea Flag went up 8%,
SMC went up 5%, Seongmin Semiconductor went up 5%, and
Jeongcheon Tech went up 4%.
Consumer goods and cigarette
stocks continued to rise yesterday due to an influx of funds buying at low prices.  Regulatory
Moses rose by 0.88%, and Yeongyang by
0.8%.  Household-related stocks showed strong gains due
to expectations such as July household export data
.
Medi Club inflammation 4% trade home
inflammation 4% has risen.  Meanwhile,
Heungseung Tech's large-cap stocks all surged.
Hyungtoon is up 3.8%.
Based on a 5-day period, it rose by 11.4%
.  Ari Paba
went extreme yesterday at 12.2% and 12%.
With that friendship, it went up 15%, Behadier went up
2.88, and Testmi went up nearly 10%
.  It
even went up 17% over the past week.  On the other hand,
the journey of PCB CC and related stocks
appeared endless.  Seungin Tech dropped
3.5% and
Jeong dropped 2.4%.
Electric vehicle-related stocks have also dropped significantly.
C-tier room dropped by 3%.  Yesterday, regarding the specific interest
rate of the belief material, I was told to do Yeomjeong 3b
.  The concrete interest rate for the monument is said to be
around 1b, and the Oeyama
exchange rate is cut to about 15%
.  thank you   I do
n't know if it's a coincidence, but it seems like the 10 cents have been
going up ever since the day Manager Wang took the picture.
Oh yes, that's a shame.  [Laughs] That was a
shame.  Ah, I only talk and can't
do the action.   that's
right.  I can't do action scenes.   I've been
talking about this a lot since the beginning, but I
couldn't take action.
There wasn't any particular issue with the rebound yesterday, but I slightly shifted my focus—
oh, not exactly—since last year, I've been consistently going long on the
Hong Kong Hong Show and the Gun's Opening, and I
took this as a long show pair.
So, recently, the military performance was
adjusted, so the Long Show pair probably
went up a bit due to supply and demand reasons.   hmm.  yes
.  When you mentioned it earlier, you could also
view it as the Shanghai Index or the ChiNext
.  The index and the Hang Seng Tech
index were moving in completely opposite directions.
This usually happens when platform companies listed in Hong Kong are strong.  So, that is how we should understand it in the broad sense, right
?   yes
.  you're right.   yes
.  And regarding the stock market trading volume, when I
asked a few days ago,
yes.  Uh, I
thought the benchmark would be around 3 trillion won in my mind.  So, if it was well above
3 trillion won, the trading volume was quite
high.  If it is less than that, I plan to
think of it that way going forward.
Yes.  yes.
Uh, the stock market trading volume here is based on the Shanghai
Index, right?  no.  It is a container.   It is the whole thing
.  Then it would actually be
easier for me to [snor] that. The
Korean market has been doing very poorly day after day, but
looking at yesterday, the
trading volume seemed very high.
So, there are usually various signals that indicate a stock price has bottomed out, and
I believe one of them is trading volume
.  From the perspective of trading volume, the domestic stock market is showing
very strong buying interest, with the view being that now is a good time to buy at low prices.   I do
n't think it goes that far.   yes
.  That is how I view the sex right now.
You know the level of Lee Jeong Yojeo.
It feels like it is quite strong because it is a bit of a watchful spirit.   If you
do 3 trillion or more, it's just fine.   If by
any chance it works out, it's just really yes.  It is
something that is done a lot.  Yes. I
understand very well.  The Korean market is a bit different because the Chinese market has
relatively less volatility and price drops compared to Korea.
Yesterday, while
looking at the Korean market, I clicked on the stocks I was watching. The trading volume was
quite
high, so although I
couldn't see the total volume, I wanted to ask because it occurred to me that many people are buying now, believing that
this is the short-term bottom
.   yes
.  If my memory is
n't mistaken,
I think this trending stock is one I'm seeing for the first time.
no.   You're
wrong. Yes, it's
Insper.  The company is a server
company.  It is a company that makes servers.   It is a
company that owns a server plant.
The market price is just over 25 trillion, and it is Poder Pia
Sensi.
Ah, companies that own servers—
yes, companies that own servers—but
companies that manufacture and sell those servers are basically the
same.  It will work.  Uh,
casting on the global server works about 2 times
.  MS is ranked first in the 10% range
.  I'm
ranked 1st on the Chinese server.  And in Chunggu, AS
server casting is 1st place.  It accounts for 55%
.  Based on last year's revenue,
server revenue accounts for
94% and article revenue for 5.9%
.  Uh uh, last year, last year, at all,
that uh, provisional results have been released.   The
expected increase in the third quarter ranges from 225% to 288%.  If there is a reverse preference, the
agreement for the second game
surges from 494% to 643%, and I
estimate the profit to be roughly between 2 billion and 2.5 billion.   The
preliminary value for the market entry team is only 1 billion yuan
.  So, this 1 billion yuan
comparison was a huge success.  So, it
seems like yesterday's event was 10% successful right away.   As of the
end of last year, the ranking is around 2.4 billion, so it is
not in the bar.  So, for the second minute, it almost went over
to just one spirit.
There is no room to freely give MP margin schedules.
Oh, China's Bin Big Tech big tech company
achieved a false performance by attaching a server order to the market with the investment of a collaboration partner.   The
GP margin fairy for the first quarter is 4%
.  With the consent rate expanding by 3% and the
increase in server supply, there is a
possibility of further improvement in the GP yield rate for Unit 2
.  In particular, there was a conference yesterday
. Regarding what this company mentions, starting from the
4th unit,
there is a possibility of practical plastic surgery following the advice and EHB video.
So, you can look forward to this part.
Looking at the older model Cheonggwansa refurbished,
based on the investment scale of China Gaoshan A, it attracted a
buy opinion expecting a successful actual trade
.
Sales for this year and next year are estimated to increase by approximately 55.4%, 4%,
57%, and 42% for each district, and by
102%,
70%, and 60% compared to the previous year for each ranking.   If you consider the
reverse preference, the original expected PR is
about 20 times, but next year it is only 13 times and
next year it is only 12 times.  If we
apply 20x multiplier to Takero next year,
there is a possibility that the TP will be around 113.
Yesterday, it was still down more than 40% compared to the previous price
.
Currently, the multiple is about 30 times.
Yes.
Uh, the very last line of the prediction is an estimated
21x.   yes
.   If you say '
uh,' I'm
sorry.  If we assume the expected PER is
20x, even
though a multiple ten times lower than the current one is being applied, the
TP is still up there.
Then that means profits will skyrocket.
Yes. Regarding this issue, when we used that Ford
here, we just
used the original Gunsus standard.  I haven't been able to
reflect it yet because it was consumed due to the earnings announcement yesterday
.  So, once everything is reflected, it can
come out like this.   What do you
call the strong re-estimation of performance?  yes.  Even if a
low multiple is applied as it is adjusted upward, the TP will be
higher than the current 113th committee member
.   You are
mentioning a 44% upside; is
this the opinion of Woori Kookmin Securities
?  no.   yes
.  Ah, that TP is our opinion.   yes
.  Gunryeoncheong [clears throat]
just didn't present the TP.
The miner thinks about this much.
That's right. On average, this industry has
roughly a blood price of 20.
And this company, Inspur, has a
structure where they just buy other parts, sell them, and sell them.  So the rate of return is
n't that high either.  It's not on the 1.5% bar
.
Companies with this kind of business model include
Industrial and Poscon, you know.   The
Force Power MP Owner is showing 3%
.  So, roughly speaking, I think 3% could
come out again.  Because
POSCO bought Nvidia's house and is
distributing it again outside the company, while these companies
bought China's Gushanchi and received it from a Chinese company
.  [Clears throat]
So, since Chinese companies
cannot purchase overseas products, they can only use this cash cow
.   You need to
look at it carefully like this.   hmm.
So now, with the rise of IT, regarding
China's attempt to directly establish its own IT ecosystem,
yes.
I think it is one of those companies that has technological capabilities and is getting attention.  yes.
yes.  If it were that kind of company, our Manager Wang would
definitely have introduced me, but
I couldn't remember, so I did it myself
.   yes
.  Looking at the bottom, it
seems like the valuation has been re-rated over a long period of time.
Looking at the PERP-BR charts of the companies that Manager Wang has been showing recently, they are
located at the very bottom of a certain band, which I consider a buying opportunity at a low price,
or
yes, companies that have skyrocketed in value over the past year.
However,
seeing that the multiples have been steadily increasing for about two or three years, I think these could be
stocks worth holding onto.   I have thought about that a bit, too
.
Yes, that is correct.
All right.  I was part of a good company.
thank you  I've heard up to here today.
Okay, let's move on to the US market.   Assistant Manager
Seoyoung is probably
resting well right now, and then we are
moving on to Yuri Pro and Changmin.
When the two women are in front, it
disrupts the camera perspective, and even though I
am standing far behind them, my head looks
much more covered up, but
Sangmin's program looks similar.
[Laughs] It is
actually much bigger when I see it in person, but I am
glad it looks a bit smaller due to the camera's sense of distance.  Pro Jang Min,
how was yesterday? Let's hear a little about it.   yes
.  I will report on the US market yesterday
.  Yesterday, the U.S. market saw
oil prices surge as the U.S. and Iran exchanged airstrikes,
resulting in a day with some variation across indices.
If you look at the major indices first, the Zhou was the weakest, falling 1.09%
.  The SP 500 closed
down about 0.3%.  On the other hand, the
Nasdaq closed higher, rising 0.2%, and
above all, the Philippine Index
rebounded 2.23%, which can be
seen as partially recovering the sharp decline from the day before yesterday
.  Russell showed a decline of about 0.8% to 8%
.  Next,
if you look at the S&P 500 sectors on the right, the
energy sector closed higher, rising 1.5%
.  Government and technology rose 1.4%, so
both sectors—or rather,
only these two sectors—rose.  Most of the remaining sectors closed lower
.  Materials
fell the most, by 2.5%.
Financials fell by 1.9%, while consumer discretionary and real estate
each fell by 1.6%.  The
surge in oil prices has affected fuel-cost sensitive stocks
.  Cruise Carnival fell
3.9%, Air BM fell 3.9%, and
Delta Port fell 1.5%.  Consumer stocks
in general also showed a somewhat weak performance.
Conversely, in the energy sector, Occidental
rose 3.7%, Eoji 2.3%, and Seven 1.1%.  It appears to be a market where the
benefits and losses from the surge in oil prices have been somewhat divided at the sector level
.
Next, looking at interest rates and oil prices, the 10-year
government bond yield rose above PP to
4.58%.  We
have reached the highest level in just one month.   The
two-year yield also rose to 4.21%
.  Oil prices
surged 6.1% to $74.7 based on WTI.
It's 7 dollars.  Brent has also risen to the $79 level
.  For your reference, the
increase in the US strategic coverage rate is
around 320,000, which is the lowest level since 1983
.
So, it appeared that the buffer against supply shocks had become somewhat
thin, so I
thought that the sensitivity to oil prices might be a bit high.
Next, if you look at the major big tech stocks on the left, there
was a bit of a difference in sentiment here as well; with
Nvidia rising 3.7% and Broadcom
4.8%, the AI ​​hardware
sector showed some strength.
In the semiconductor sector as well, SanDisk rose 6.8% and 8%,
Applied Matte 2.9%,
Micron 1.1%, and TMC 1%,
showing an overall rebound.
On the other hand, Meta dropped 2.0%.
Tesla fell 2.2%, and
Microsoft and Google each
fell 1.4%, showing some weakness in the platform sector
.  It appears that the
hardware and hyperscaler dynamic that had persisted until recently
reappeared yesterday
.
Then, I will report on the United States, which was at the core of the disruption yesterday, and provide
updates on the situation so far.
Oh, in
response to the attack on a merchant ship in the Strait of Hormuz on Tuesday, the U.S. Central Command launched airstrikes on Iran's
air defense and drone launch facilities
.  Iran claimed to have struck
85 U.S. military facilities in Bahrain and Cowait, and
retaliated.   In
addition, the U.S. Treasury Department revoked the sanctions exemption for the sale of Iranian crude oil
.
At a NATO press conference, President Trump showed a
tough stance, stating that he would respond tenfold if Iran attacked
.  It appeared that they drew a line against escalation, stating that
it does not constitute a declaration of war and that the situation would
end very quickly
. If
you look at the nature of this conflict,
all the merchant ships attacked by Iran since the ceasefire were vessels that did
not follow the Khurmouzu route established by Iran
.
Ah, since it is a free route and
unrelated to profit, the fact that they are attacking it
seems like an intention to solidify the route as the official one.   I can say that
the United States appears to be upholding the freedom of navigation of the 50,000-mile route
.  Ultimately, it appears to have been
more of a conflict over control of the strait route rather than an all-out war
.  So, I think that ultimately, it can be
settled through some negotiation
.  Next, let's go
down to the individual stocks section and look at
Broadcom, which rose 4.8% yesterday
.  Apple has signed a
massive, long-term chip manufacturing
contract worth over $30 billion with Broadcom to expand semiconductor production in the U.S.  This is the largest
investment related to U.S. manufacturing that Apple has announced to date
.  And yes, an article said that $1.5 billion is being invested
in the Prodcon plant in Fort Collins, Colorado, to
expand facilities and produce over $15 billion worth of American-made homes
.  On the 6th, the two companies
announced that they would expand ASIC cooperation until 2031, and with the figures for the amount and
facility investment now becoming concrete, I would
say that this is now within sight.
So, it
appears that this part acted as a driving force for the stock price increase.
Next, I will speak about NB.   The
NBA showed a 3.7% increase in China-related reports
.  Although not yet confirmed,
reports suggest that the Chinese
government plans to allow
major AI companies such as Alibaba, ByteDance, and Discord to purchase a
limited quantity of NBI H200s to address the severe domestic AI shortage
.  Therefore, although the
Trump administration previously
approved the export of the H200 to China, the Chinese government had been delaying
purchase approval to protect its domestic semiconductor industry; however, it appears they have partially softened their stance as securing
high-performance components has become increasingly
difficult and the U.S. crackdown on smuggling has intensified
.  Therefore,
I believe the market interpreted this as a signal that sales in China, which had been somewhat blocked, could actually resume, rather than focusing on the volume itself
.
Next, Meta showed a 2.0% decline
.  They announced that they are building Canada's first
data center.   It is
planned to be a bit small, with an investment of about $10 billion and a 1GW facility.  It was announced that it would be primarily
powered by millennium gas power and would run Meta's own AI model and existing
social media
.  So, given that this is the first facility to be built in Canada, it
appears to be news that infrastructure expansion is being broadened.   yes
.  Perhaps because of
the news about increased investment in K-Pax, the stock price actually
appeared to fall.
So, to summarize today's content, while
geopolitics is shaking the market through oil prices and interest rates, it
appears that the conflict is continuing as a means of negotiation rather than an escalation.
It appears that the center of gravity of the market was trying to shift somewhat toward the home.  That's all.
Thank you. The 52 trillion won reported price in the middle is
blank, but it does
n't seem like it's part 5 here; it
looks like it wasn't there.  There was no god.   uh
.   yes
.   I do
n't remember when I saw you, but
you're so cute.  Yesterday, the Dow continued to
fall by more than 1% relative to the nine-week high, and since most of the companies currently rising from their lows
are in the SMP 500 and Nasdaq, it
seems there were no 52-week highs.  Uh,
considering that both government bond yields and oil prices are continuously moving within a certain range,
paradoxically, if we assume that rates and oil prices are
somewhere at the upper end of the band we expect, then we should buy a bit at this point, and if we think they
won't fall too sharply, we should
sell more at the bottom.
Viewing it as a range-bound market where we need to trade in the opposite way, I wondered if there might have been an investment sentiment yesterday suggesting that it would be difficult for oil or
interest rates to rise higher than they are now
.  As I was commuting to work this morning listening to the news, I heard
that President Trump had clarified that the airstrike on Iran was
merely a short-term strike. It occurred to me that the
U.S.
clearly does not want this to be perceived as an escalation or a prolonged conflict, which is why they are
utilizing the media in this manner
.  In this section, we will
take a closer look at the U.S. market with Vice President Cheilo.  Let's move on to virtual assets
.  Junhyeok,
my recent feeling is that virtual assets are
holding up well for the sake of $60,000.  I have a broad idea in that framework, but I am
curious.
What happened?   yes
.  If you look at 24 Gaeun first.  You can
see that the Bitcoin market, a household asset market, continues to trade above around $62,000
.  Hey, the
reason I said the level around $62,000 is important is that historically, the
200-day moving average... uh, the 200-day moving average...
ah, I'm sorry.  I mentioned that the 200 level had consistently
acted as a bottom, and I find it
quite significant that it held that level well—both psychologically and technically—despite the occurrence of short-term geopolitical issues.
Anyway, although it went up to $61,000 yesterday, the fact that it is
holding above $6,000 and even above the
200-week moving average at this point, as the daily candle is closing out, can be
viewed very positively
.  Yesterday, I
mentioned that tranche risks or Trump's airstrike on Iran would likely have a somewhat limited impact on the preference for the stock market or risky assets. But
no, no, no, it won't have any impact at all.
Oh, right,
I spoke quite strongly.
[Laughs] I didn't just say it would be limited; I
said it wouldn't have any impact at all.
Yesterday, oil prices did rise slightly, and while that was a
factor, if we
look at the Bitcoin market or the US stock market yesterday, I believe the trends you
mentioned earlier—contrarian trading anticipating a range-bound trend in government bond yields—are
continuing
.  For example, if an
attack like the one yesterday had
led to a definitive conclusion, I would have
thought that a much larger plunge in Bitcoin should have occurred. However, the
fact that such a thing did not happen suggests that, as the
CEO mentioned, contrarian trading or a
trend of disbelief in the Bitcoin market—or perhaps a disregard for the war—is
continuing
.  Uh, I think I
should just briefly explain about the war.
Uh, regarding this war, uh,
last week, Heeney's funeral was held.
So, it is said that Heeney's
funeral was held this week.  So,
regarding Heeney, that length...
it seems there are a lot of opinions saying that they didn't attack until the memorial space ended, but then raised the attack again. There was a NATO meeting yesterday as well
.  Right before the NATO meeting,
uh, Trump—ah, not
Trump—made a statement saying to cut off all trade with Spain.
So, personally, I suspect that this might have been one of the cards intended to put significant pressure on NATO, or specifically on Spain, a NATO
ally.
Ultimately, I believe
Trump intended to
politically or geopolitically
utilize the missile bombing that took place in Hormush, and I
think this sentiment was reflected in the market.  If
you look at the long-term chart, as I mentioned earlier, it is
holding well against the 200-week moving average.  Uh, you can just take
note of the fact that this part is invincible
.  Uh,
if you look at the Bitcoin hit grid index, it is located in the extreme fear
zone, uh, and
is recording around 20.  Uh, a slight but
positive aspect is that the net outflow from Bitcoin spot ETFs has
recently been
continuing as an inflow
.  So, uh, it came in around
July 7th, but
anyway,
in the sense that the outflow has stopped a bit, it seems that the market is still having a
significant impact on the Bitcoin price
.  Uh,
if you look at the side with the caution.  An article like this came out yesterday, so I
brought it here.  There was a report
from Duinf stating that stablecoins have gone their separate ways, with USDT capturing payments and USDC capturing deposits
.  A Du is an
on-chain analysis period.  As you
mentioned yesterday, there is an online analysis organization called Dewey that effectively tracks such on-chain
activities and
publishes analysis articles
.  It is said that while
Tether's USDT has
become the dominant payment stablecoin in the crypto market,
Circle's USDC is
driving the growth of DeFi.
DeFi refers to decentralized
trading or smart contracts, which are
transactions conducted without any intermediaries
.  It is said that the top two market-leading
stablecoins are
gradually establishing themselves as
financial products specialized for specific uses, rather than engaging in a head-on battle with the crypto ecosystem, by performing different roles
.  So, as I mentioned earlier,
Tether's USDT has been shown to hold an
overwhelming share of the on-chain payment sector.
However, considering that
during the first half of 2026, USDT
settled approximately 95 billion in commercial payments,
while USDC
settled about 14 billion, it seems the scale itself is at
least four to five times larger
.  Also,
since USDT accounted for about 92% of the 48 billion B2B payment volume,
we can confirm that USDT is being used extensively in the payment sector
.  Uh,
regarding Tron, the largest network for USDT—
uh, as I mentioned earlier, you can think of it like
subway lines 9 or 7—it is said that
93% of the token supply on the network is held in regular wallets rather than exchanges, so it plays a
good role as an asset for payments and transfers.
This is a somewhat important point.   If something is
on an exchange, it
is essentially similar to chips in a casino, so there is a
very high probability that it will be utilized for activities within the exchange.  However, regarding the fact that it is
held in a regular wallet, I
think you should understand that it is correct to keep it there for the purpose of sending it from one wallet to another person's wallet in order to make a payment.  You can think of it as similar to keeping our
money in a
personal physical wallet, rather than topping it up like online cash
.  On the other hand, USDC has
established itself as the dominant stablecoin in the DeFi sector, and
USDC, based
on the Ethereum network, recorded the highest figure among all token chain combinations by processing a transaction volume of $2.6 trillion last June, while USDC on the Ethereum network
processed approximately $1.6 trillion.  It is said that the base-
based USDC reflected its widespread utility in trading and DeFi, recording a daily circulation velocity in June with its
circulating supply reaching approximately 20 times
.
These analysis results suggest that the existing competitive landscape regarding
which would capture more market share, USDT or USDC, is
no longer valid
.  Instead, it was mentioned that each
stablecoin is
carving out its own territory, with USDT
dominating the payment sector and USDC
supporting a significant portion of crypto trading and DeFi activities
.  I mentioned that while the supply of USDT
is evenly divided between Tron and Ethereum, USDC is
still heavily concentrated on Ethereum, even though it is expanding as a new blockchain. You can understand it as such
.  So, I am
explaining the last sentence and the photo on the first left
. This blue and orange
part is USDT.  So, I
think you can confirm that the USDT stablecoin still accounts for more than 60% of the total stablecoins.  The gray area is USDC.
So, rather than USDC taking
away USDT's market share, it
seems they wanted to explain that stablecoins are growing slightly in their respective use cases.   You
can take a look at the photo on the right.  I brought an article from the right
.
I previously mentioned that about
180 companies,
including particularly Korean firms, had formed a
consortium through consultation and were entering the
US STIBLCOIN
market to take it over, and the
follow-up
articles seem to have been quite shocking
.  It was a follow-up report stating that
many of the companies included in the USD had no related consultations
.  So, it seems there is growing skepticism about how
many of the 180 companies have actually entered this concert
test
.  Uh, as I just mentioned,
USDT and USDC
hold a significant share of the market. We can prove
this by the fact that, like the original currency and the
dollar, they are already familiar to users and have secured a position, whether it be
10% or 60%.
Seeing the OpenUSD consortium already faltering,
doubts have formed from the very beginning regarding how much market share it can seize
. You can just look at the flow of events up to this point
.   hmm.
Uh, it seems very difficult for us to actually feel whether people are using this USBT
.  Because, uh,
actually, what we use right now is cards, and
since fintech is so well-developed, we make all our payments with cards and
use Samsung Pay and Apple Pay a lot. There is a very famous influencer named iShow Speed ​​who does this
.
When iShow Speed ​​was traveling in Nigeria, he asked, "Uh, does Apple Pay work?" and
received a rejection that it does not.  But
when I asked if you had seen USDT, you allowed it, so I
made the payment in USDT.   It
was a very large amount, and there was a
famous influencer demonstrating a real-world use case of payment using the stablecoin USDT, although it was
early this year.  So, while
such things are
not actually used in financial powerhouses like ours, I would say that the widespread use of USDT payments is a
real phenomenon in countries with less favorable financial conditions, excluding our country
.   If
you look at the one on the upper side, it is the
turnover rate, which is a figure showing
how quickly currency circulates
.  You
just need to look at the graph at the very top, which
is USC. It is USBC running
on the base rail of this base chain, and the fact that the turnover
rate is high suggests that there is a
very high volume of trading on it
.  So, you
can view this chart as one designed to support the fact that USDC is being used very actively in the D-wave section.  That's all.
thank you
For those of you who, like me, are still not very familiar with the virtual currency market, shall we briefly review the very
first points you mentioned regarding the major issues—
what USDT and USDC are
?   yes
.  You can consider USDT to be what Tether, or
Circle—which is listed in the U.S.—operates, and
USDC to be.   hmm.
[Clears throat] USDT is backed by
Tether, which has some Hong Kong capital mixed in.  So, USDC is
run by Circle. I think that should suffice. As for
USDT, it is run by
Hong Kong capital that is not yet listed
.  So, you
can view USDC Circle as a more transparent and regulated stablecoin, whereas
USDT is a relatively opaque stablecoin with Hong Kong capital mixed in. If you
delve deeper into the fact that USDC has secured a deposit, it is closely
related to the CLEET Act
.  Because the
things currently being included in the Klet Act are intended to
further revitalize DeFi, and the SA, SAC, and
CFT are joining forces to promote
on-chain
transactions without intermediaries and to
clarify regulations—that is what the Klet
Act is all about.
However, the fact that USDC is taking the lead there suggests that
we can confirm to some extent that the U.S. is trying to significantly expand USDC into the DeFi sector, which I
think was a good point.   You can
view this as the same trend as the U.S., which is said to have many issues, currently activating the CLETA Act to clarify definitions and place them above regulations
.
Thank you.  Since it is not a relatively US-based
platform,
USDT...
how should I put it?  So,
rather than being connected to DeFi, it focuses a little more on payments
.  It seems like you could view it this way, but there are
actually many connections.  If
regulations really shift in a direction favorable to the U.S.
and where it must fall within the regulatory framework, then the trend will
gradually shift
toward USDC; consequently, USDT will
naturally have no choice but to move toward the end, while
USDC will naturally have
no choice but to move toward the side that is regulated.
People practically give away money in gold, but we
don't track all the cash, do we?  yes.  You can simply view it as working together with that aspect
.  UST is used as cash, while
USC is used on-chain—that is,
as actual traceable money
. You can view it roughly in this flow
.  Studying is necessary for everything.   I will start by reviewing it a
bit more diligently and repeatedly
.  We will conclude Part 1 here
.  We will see you briefly on the upper floor with more
details.
Thank you to everyone at Chaeulton for joining us.
[Music]
เฮ
Hello.  We will begin the second part of the
Chesley Morning
Brief today, Thursday, July 9, with investment expert Chesley, for a happy investment schedule
.
Yesterday, the US market showed some partial
weakness, but the Nasdaq and
Philippine indices began to rebound.
One regrettable point is that the 10-year government bond yield is
at 4.58
and oil prices are starting from 6%.
Yes, that is correct.
yes.  It's a bit of a shame that it was shown.
yes.
However, since Middle Eastern issues
always return to normal, whenever the
market falls due to war in the Middle East, a
rebound always follows.
yes.
Yesterday, it was said that a rebound would occur in the Chesley Index if the number of real-time participants—not just
real-time views—exceeded 2,000. However,
yesterday it
failed to surpass 2,000 won and
dropped to 1,900 with around 80 participants.
Unfortunately, our market did show signs of panic again yesterday
.
I noticed that the foreigners bought everything at the last minute.  Foreign god.
yes.  Then, an individual sold it for the first time in a while
.
It wasn't that the individual wanted to sell it; it was a
forced opposition.
yes.
Because such signs emerged, and the
noise coming from the US market further worsened investment sentiment, it
affected the Korean market. However, the
news heard last night that
Meta is
investing in a data center in Alberta, Canada.
So, the news suggests that
Meta needs to rearrange its computing resources
.  So, with
talk like this coming out, aren't you saying you won't invest anymore?
If you expressed some concerns like that, then
yesterday's first data center
investment in Canada... uh, what is this?  I have a
thought like this.
yes.  That is correct.
What is the content?
yes.  So, the
starting point of this market volatility is Meta's data center
.  Uh, well, I will sell the remaining new computing resources
to a third party.  It all
started with this, but looking at Meta's
moves yesterday, there is absolutely
no reason for them to be passive about investing in AI infrastructure.
It seems like they gave a message like this.   As you
mentioned, they announced that they would invest 10 billion dollars in Canada's first data
center.
Meta already had 32 data centers, and with
this addition, it amounts to
building a total of 33 data centers
.  Uh, Alberta is a small province in Canada
called Sturgeon County, which is the area marked with a dotted line and is circled for
2,000 won
.  As you know,
Canada has a vast land area and a low population density. Prime
Minister Carney was
elected with the slogan that Canada would become the world's leading nation for data center construction, and he is
very
active in attracting data centers. I
think this aligns perfectly with Meta's goal of infrastructure investment.  The power
capacity is about 1 GW, which you can consider to be
equivalent to the power consumption of 750,000 households, and
most of the electricity is generated from 1,000-won gas thermal power plants
.  And it is said that Menta
plans to connect to the Elbota power grid by directly funding the new power generation facility
.   The
employment effect involves about 3 construction workers
.  It is said that about 300 regular employees will work there after completion, and
the purpose is to operate the company's own AI models and social
media apps such as Instagram and Facebook. It is
also said that they are reviewing a move into the cloud business to sell separate surplus computing capacity to external companies.
So this part is really important. There
is constant talk that Meta is planning to enter the cloud business in earnest, and if that happens, existing
players like Microsoft, Amazon, and
Google will
likely become nervous.
Mark Zuckoberg, the CEO of Meta,
has a very aggressive tendency. During the upcoming earnings announcement,
comments regarding AI capital expenditures will be released. It remains to be seen
how those comments will be delivered; whether they will
reinforce the overall trend in AI infrastructure—not just for cloud providers—
or go in the opposite direction is a
situation that is attracting significant attention.   As I
mentioned earlier, the background is that
Metadinisi
aligned with Prime Minister Carney's slogan to make Canada the world's leading nation for data center construction.  [Snoring]
So, I heard that Alberta eased its power industry
regulations last year.  In the case of the U.S.,
data center construction is reportedly being delayed due to environmental
regulations, opposition from residents, and other
factors.
However, in the case of Canada, judging by the fact that
such regulations are being relaxed, I
thought that they might establish this as a major main site for future data center construction and potentially expand further. As for the implications, as you also
hinted, the
investment in the Canadian data center goes
beyond simply expanding internal AI infrastructure; it suggests that Meta is
considering a long-term role as a cloud provider selling AI computing to external customers. The
narrative that caused market volatility earlier this month was that Meta could sell surplus AI computing
capacity, which was
interpreted to mean they possessed internal infrastructure. Consequently, there were concerns that their aggressive
AI CAPEX might have been excessive relative to demand, potentially
slowing the momentum for AI infrastructure. However,
this
expansion of investment in the Canadian data center seems to alleviate concerns regarding a reduction in Meta's AI CAPEX infrastructure.
Meta's data center
clearly confirms its position for expanding its cloud service business, and competition with existing service
providers such as Microsoft, Amazon, and
Google is
expected. Furthermore, I
believe that this competition among cloud service providers could potentially lead to increased investment in AI infrastructure
.
So, from an investment perspective, it has been proven that Meta's AI
investment can be oversaturated and accelerated, and as
long as strong demand continues, the possibility of cloud service
providers expanding their investments is also
expected to increase.  Uh, Bank
of America recently
updated the CAPEX investments of those hyperscalers, and I
specifically looked at the Meta side.
Bank America showed a trend of other operators also continuously raising their estimates. Looking at Meta's
CAPEX estimates compared to Bloomberg and
Bank America's current estimates, it stands at
135.20 in 2026. However,
Bloomberg's estimate was 135,
and
Bank America
raised its previous estimate to 145, resulting in a
difference of about 10 years.
In 2027, Bloomberg's estimate was 162,
and Bank Mary's was 185. In 2028,
Bank Mary went from 178 to 210. I do
n't know if this upward revision will continue or if it is just Bank America's own estimate, but in any case, Bank America
preemptively
raised its estimate faster than others.
Right now, Meta
is trading at about 14.6 times its PR.  As
CAPEX continues to be pursued in earnest, I think the stock
price will likely
remain within that trading range or see a slight contraction in valuation.
However, from an investment perspective, regardless of this, I
anticipate that the AI ​​infrastructure sector will gain further momentum.  So, the way to
get a glimpse of the forward demand situation for cloud providers is by looking at the market
share of cloud businesses by enterprise in the cloud market status below. As you are
well aware, Microsoft and
Amazon hold the top spot with 28%, while
Microsoft Azure
accounts for 21% and Google Cloud for
14%, having
jumped from single digits to double digits
.  Next, it's roughly even, with
Oracle at about 4%, Alibaba at 4%,
Cells Force, Huawei,
Tencent, and so on.   This is the market
share of cloud service providers based on revenue as of the first quarter of 2026.  For reference, in the first quarter of 2026, the
total revenue for the cloud was
approximately $129 billion.  So,
roughly speaking, if you multiply this by 4, you can
consider the market size to be around 500 billion dollars
.  However, the important thing is that if you
look at the cloud service market size and growth rate, the growth rate itself was declining as of the third quarter of 2023,
but as of the third quarter of 2023, it is
now accelerating.  So,
looking at each quarter, the
quarterly year-on-year
growth rate has risen from about 18% at that time to 36%.
So, demand itself appears to be quite solid, and while it
varies slightly depending on the research institution, there
seems to be a consensus that it will record a growth rate of roughly 30 to 40% by 2030.
So, among the top four companies, if we
look at the revenue growth related to cloud services over the two years of 2025 and 2026, Amazon is the number one
provider, having
achieved about 120 billion in 2025.  Uh, it is
expected to be about 167 billion this year
.  About 30% with one Yi
.  And Microsoft
Cloud recorded about 106 billion in 2025 and is
expected to show growth of around 30% to 137 billion in 2026. Meanwhile,
Google Cloud is growing dramatically, with
revenue expected to rise from 58.7 billion in 2025
to 96.8 billion in 2026, with a
growth rate of 65%.  And in the
case of OraCloud, 66% growth is expected
from 34 billion in 2025 to 56 billion in 2026
.  With
many contracts related to Open AI being reflected, it
seems the growth rate will continue to strengthen in the future.
So, looking at the overall picture, with the
demand for the upstream segment of the cloud business
continuing to fluctuate in the mid-to-high 30% range, and
infrastructure investments by cloud providers—commonly referred to as hyperscalers—
expected to continue increasing, if
Meta, which has been
building only its own AI infrastructure,
aggressively jumps into the cloud business, would
n't competition among hyperscalers intensify further?  Then, I
think that ultimately, the concerns about the downsizing of AI infrastructure that were present at the beginning of the month might be somewhat alleviated.   That's
all.
yes.  But right now, regarding the
cloud service market size
and growth rate above, you know   Yeah,
yeah.   Is it
correct that this is the total global worldwide market size?  Yes,
that is correct.  If you look to the side, you know that
chart next to it shows Cloud
Infrastructure
Q1 2026.  This is
[clears throat] a total of
129 billion years.   In the
first quarter,
yes, in the first quarter, in one quarter,
yes, so next to it, uh, this is also
marked up to the first quarter of 2026, right?
The one on the left is the size.  The
one on the right is the yyy growth rate, and if you look at the left, the
bar graph is now around 131 years
.  That
example.  yes.  So, when we
combined the market share of all companies and their revenue for the first quarter of 2026, it
came out to about 129 billion. You
can view that as an increase of about 36% year-on-year, and the
growth rate itself is continuously
accelerating on a quarter-by-quarter basis.  Hey,
looking at this chart, the
growth rate
was dropping steadily from around 37 as we transitioned from 2020 to 2021 and 2022, but the fact that the
growth rate started rising steeply again from the second half of 2023 is
due to AI.  Right?
yes.
Exactly in the fourth quarter of 2022,
in November, OpenAI
released Chaji, didn't they?  yes.  And at the same time, it
seems to be gradually accelerating from that period onward.  It
is 130 billion in one quarter,
showing a growth rate of over 30%.
So, I did a rough calculation, and if we
look at this year and next, it will
be about 700.7 billion, which is
almost a 1 trillion market.
Yes, that is correct.  It's becoming a huge market
.  hmm.
And
Amazon and Microsoft
together account for 50%, while
Alphabet and Google are trying to reach about 15%.
Below them are Oracle, Alibaba, Huawei,
Tencent, and so on, with the
top companies making up about 60% of the total
.  It is.
This is how it hardens.  Right?
yes.  It seems things have solidified like this, and the key
factor now is how Meta will handle the situation
.
Meta doesn't have any presence yet, does he?   There is
n't at all.  Because they
weren't providing cloud services and had been focusing only on internal operations, AI, and
infrastructure expansion, but this time
, they
announced that they would even start selling cloud services
.   uh
.
Meta's stock price dropped yesterday, didn't it?
Yes, it is missing.
So, in a
way, there
are established big players, and below them, formidable companies in the 4% and 2% sectors
are all positioned
. Yes,
Meta is going to provide cloud services as a
latecomer.
yes.
So, hey, do you think it'll work to jump in right now as a latecomer
?  Did you evaluate it somewhat like that
?  So, anyway,
whenever Meta announces that it is investing aggressively, the
perspective
seems to be based on past memories of the metaverse—specifically, the trauma and lingering remnants of when it failed to achieve results.  So, I think there is a bit of a wait-and-see attitude or concern this time as well
regarding how aggressively and effectively they will perform
.
yes.  So
yes.  You know how it went up
8% when Meta said they were selling the relationship infrastructure?
At that time, the market sentiment was, "Would
n't Meta be more efficient by selling off the surplus instead of making additional investments?"
If that sentiment was strong, the
news about Canada's data center expansion that came out yesterday
seems to be a bit different in nature.
But earlier, while looking at that map of Canada,
hey, that
land called Gwanghwa, right?
yes.  There was also
talk recently about our country's semiconductor factories, such as water shortages and such. If you
look at the Ontario section above those five, it says
Hudson Bay
.
yes.
So, Canada can use this data center, right?
yes.  Exactly.
I understand, since there is also one right nearby in the U.S.  You also went into detail about Meta's
announcement of its first data center investment in Canada
.
So, uh, but regarding the overall cloud market today,
[clears throat] I didn't know the market size,
but the cloud market is in the trillions of dollars. The
Y-Ross is currently
rising steeply, and high growth exceeding 30% is
continuing.   A
relationship that was remembered and moved on from like this,
for example.  yes.  So, from Meta's
perspective, they are also jumping into this high-growth business
.
It seems like that happened because they tried this and that on their own and it didn't work out.
All right.   So
then, let's move on to the domestic market
. Yes, I will
report on yesterday's market.
Oh, the KOSPI index closed down 5.3%
.  It was a day when the
market
atmosphere turned very hostile, with the KOSDAQ closing down 5.5%
.   If
you take a look at the MSC South Korea ETF, it closed yesterday with a 0.8% increase
.  The futures
showed a somewhat strong rebound.  I think the
opening price today might start a bit strongly as it rises by about 4%
.   In terms of
supply and demand, individual investors
sold 35 billion won worth of shares.  As you mentioned earlier, it
seems there was some impact from the short selling.  Foreign investors
switched to buying yesterday.  Although it was
not a large amount, there was still an
inflow of buying pressure of about 330 billion won
.  With institutional investors showing figures in the 300 million won range, the
selling pressure from the institutional side is still
being maintained.  It seems like there was some
strong buying in foreign futures
.  1.6 trillion
won in buying pressure flowed in.
Looking at trading trends by investor, foreign
investors bought SK Inix,
Samsung Electro-Mechanics,
LG Innotek, SK Square, HD
Hyundai Heavy Industries, Hyundai Motor, Hanmi Semiconductor, and
others yesterday.  Foreign
investors sold Samsung Electronics, Samsung Electronics preferred shares,
Hana Ocean, LIG, DNA, APL,
KB Financial, etc.  Institutional
buying included Samsung Electronics, SK,
Samsung Electronics preferred stock, Kia, KB Financial, etc.
On the selling side, I
sold SK Inix, Samsung Electro-Mechanics, LG Innotek, LS11, Hyundai Heavy Industries, etc.  I've
noticed recently that foreigners have been continuously buying Samsung Electro-Mechanics
.   Although it has
been falling significantly recently, there has been a continuous
inflow of around 100 billion won, so I was
curious and looked at about 60 days'
worth of data. I found that Samsung
Electro-Mechanics ranked first in net foreign buying.  Looking at it, about
1.6 trillion won worth
was purchased, followed by Hyundai Rotem, Doosan,
POSCO Holdings, Cells, Ensol, and SDI in that
order.
Is that foreign buying amount from yesterday 100 to 7 billion won?  Or it
is 170 won.
It's 1570.  [Clears throat]
I mean, I bought an amount equivalent to ten times this over the past 60 days.   yes
.  And these are the stocks that hit a 52-week high
.  Dasco, an office development company, hit a new high on the KOSPI
.  KOSDAQ
recorded new highs for C-Lab and Data Solution.
Yesterday, Dasco and Data Solution had positive disclosures, and there were
some significant contract wins
.  So, even though it is a
small stock in terms of market capitalization, it hit the
upper limit even in such market conditions.
All market caps: 110 billion, 100 billion,
100 billion, 96.4 billion.
yes.  It seems like something like this won't be available.
Looking at it from a foreigner's perspective, they bought Hynix and
sold Electronics.
[Clears throat]
As for Hynix, about ten times as much capital flowed into the ADR side
.   yes
.  Uh, it came out like this.
And the construction cost is
determined based on the average price of the last 3 days or something like that.
I haven't been able to verify that part
.  I couldn't check.   People say that
foreigners deliberately pressed the price to lower the official duty rate, but
we always have to be careful about that because there is
n't just one foreigner.  Institutions intentionally
raise stock prices, and institutions intentionally lower them; there
are hundreds of such institutions.  So if you do that,
other agencies will raise your name, so you should
beat them up.  Oh, they're pushing it, I should buy it.
Since things are this way, you can view it as not being a case of foreigners
forcibly pushing and pulling.
Even yesterday, foreigners did
buy about 160 billion won worth of Hynix.  If ten times the amount poured in, the
funds being raised this time are 45 trillion won.
yes.  Then, you are correct in saying that around 450 in the 1945s, it was concentrated a little over 450
.  yes.
And yesterday,
in a comment by Woman Simbak or something, someone mentioned why the exchange rate is falling.
Since this 45 trillion won is being raised, it is being
raised in dollars, and the point is that those raised
funds will be
invested domestically, isn't that right?   Right
?
yes.  That is correct.
Then, since the raised funds must be converted into Korean Won and
invested domestically, it
is a fairly large amount temporarily.
Yes, that is correct.
Since a fairly large amount of money is coming in, it
seemed like the impact would decrease in advance because such a large sum of capital is expected to flow in, and as you can see, foreigners
bought yesterday.
Looking at not only the KOSPI but also the KOSDAQ, futures, and options yesterday, I noticed a massive sell-off of over
40 billion won in put options.
Seeing that massive sell-off, I
mentioned in my new car analysis that the market was poised for a rebound today. With
night futures rising by 4%, I think the
opening price will likely start around 2.5 to
3.5
% higher. Let's
take a look at the videos of these stocks.   yes
.  If you are predicting the semiconductor sector, yesterday was a day when major
semiconductors plummeted again, and
even the materials, parts, and equipment sectors
recorded a significant decline.
Samsung Electronics closed down 6%, and
SK Hynix
recorded a sharp decline of 5.7%.   I
recall that the market even went into positive territory early in the session, and the index itself
rose by about 1%, but ultimately, with a lot of selling pressure, it
seems the market closed very weakly.  Uh, if you
look at the materials, parts, and equipment stocks, equipment stocks such as HPSP,
EOTech, and Jusung Engineering
generally recorded a decline of over 7%
.  The drop in prices for Ari PCBs and
materials was also quite significant.   In the
substrate sector, Daeduck Electronics and Isu Peta
saw a sharp decline of around 9%.  And in the
materials sector, Solbrain also
recorded a decline of around 4%.
Uh, if you take a look at the IT sector,
Samsung Electro-Mechanics plunged 10% yesterday.
Uh, the valuation has dropped by 50 times in an instant
.  I
remember it was over 80 times recently, but it has
dropped to 50 times.  Uh, and
I think it was notable that LG Electronics and LG Display rose in the 3% range.   The
platform sector was somewhat sluggish, with Naver and
Kakao falling in the 2% range
.  The Nikkei
index closed down in the 2% range yesterday
.  It is similar here as well.   The
semiconductor IT sector performed poorly, with Tokyo
Electron down 3%, Hoya down 6%, and stocks like
Disco 2-Biden and Advantest
showing a weak trend.   yes
.  If you look at the automotive sector, the
geometry still showed an upward trend yesterday.
Uh, on the other hand, Hyundai Motor and Hyundai AutoEver
also showed weakness.   If
you take a look at the consumer goods sector, yesterday, Saenggun
Amol had risen significantly the day before yesterday, but
yesterday, it closed with a [snor] decline
.
Cosmetic OEM and ODM were also weak.   The
Piu beauty device sector was good the day before yesterday, but it
closed with a generally weak trend yesterday.
Uh, in the food sector below, Hangsi Foods also
surged 11% the day before yesterday, but gave
back some of its gains in yesterday's trading
.
Department store stock prices haven't been doing
well recently.  Shinsegae fell 8% and Hyundai
Department Store fell 4%.  So, if you
look at the industry itself or the recent data, things like the number of foreign visitors are all in a good
situation.  However, since Shinsegae's valuation
went up to about 17 times and then
settled back down to 14 times, I
think this could actually be used as a buying opportunity.   If
you look at the shipbuilding and steel sectors,
shipbuilding stocks performed poorly.  First of all, there
was a 22% plunge the day before yesterday, and
with another sharp drop in yesterday's trading, it
seems we can view the stock price trend as having completely reversed in the short term.
With the forward valuation at 14 times, it seems the
valuation is dropping significantly to the level of a company with absolutely no growth potential
.
And regarding the steel and chemical sectors below,
yesterday, due to some war slavery issues,
oil prices fluctuated wildly during trading, and it
seems that S was affected.  Defense stocks were also
very bad yesterday.  There were
n't any particular bad news or anything like that.  Hana
Aero fell 7%, Nexon 10%, and
Hyundai Rotem 9%
.  This place has also
become much nicer.  Nex1 went up to 60 times
when the war between the US and the US intensified, reaching
60 or 70 times, but it has now dropped to 34 times
.  It's been a while since Rotem
broke the 20x multiplier.  The
biotech sector was bad yesterday.
Sanbana and Epice generally had a sluggish
trend.   hmm.
Hmm, it's been a while since I checked Samsung Bio's valuation,
but it seems to have dropped to 30 times
.  I do
n't think this company had such a low valuation before, but it has
dropped significantly, and the KOSDAQ biotech sector below was also performing
poorly.  Alteogen, A-
Bio, and Peptron were generally weak.   The
KOSDAQ biotech sector was also generally bad.
Yesterday, bank stocks showed a
solid trend compared to the market, and Kiwoom's stock performance wasn't
bad either.  In the entertainment sector,
HYBE showed gains in the morning session but
closed down 0.8% to 8% as the market retreated.  Well,
the rest of the enter controls were also endless.   The
drop in the transformer is very large.
Hyundai 1-lec, used LS 1-lec
generally showed a downward trend of over 7%
.  So, regarding the first line and
defense sectors, such as transformers and industrial products, it seems that things were actually
okay until the first half of this year, but
starting this month
and from the end of June, the stock price
trend appears to have deteriorated significantly
.   The
market atmosphere was bleak yesterday, wasn't it?
yes.  [Clears throat]
And regarding the bottom,
our country's individual investors are
usually good at
buying when prices fall and selling when they rise—they just buy when it drops and sell when it goes up—but it is a bit
unfortunate when, during the final panic selling phase, forced selling occurs. Just
when the price reaches the level where one really should be buying,
unavoidable forced selling takes place, and in that respect,
foreigners actually end up
buying.
Looking at it recently, if you just look at this part of the foreign futures market, aside from the
1 trillion won sold three days ago, there isn't much
.   yes
.  I keep buying here now
.
And stock buying needs to come in now;
about 330 billion won was bought yesterday, and as you mentioned earlier,
PUS sold over 40 billion won
.  That sale of over 40 billion won is not so much a
new sell order from yesterday, but rather an
example of realizing profits from positions that had been bought and are now generating substantial gains.  Since it can be considered around 40 billion, it seems
like there are some discrepancies for foreign option players. I
will pick out the areas I am looking at, and now, I am
receiving the same volume for these stocks.  And
seeing stocks crashing, there are really
more stocks to buy.   Jisu has
become kind too.
The index, which hit 9,300, fell to 7,200 and
went up 122% year-to-date.   yes
.
So, if it drops 20% from the peak,
that actually means 40% is gone
.  We were talking about something like that, but
now it's 71 YTD. Since it's military power, it
went from 120% to 72%, so
how much is it?  It took 50% of the trouble.   Right
?  You could say that I've
blown away the 10% profit I made from the peak,
but... ah,
I should have taken that.
[Clears throat] The thing is, you don't have to think that way. The
market sometimes drops more than expected relative to its intrinsic value, and sometimes
rises more than expected relative to that intrinsic value
.   yes
.  So, it is correct not to view that overshooting phase as necessarily
my share
.  So, it will likely be the same for each sport
.  Even by category, ah, I'm
losing everything I ate.   You see,
it's the
midterm election period. You can think of 789 as a
rough
phase where winter suddenly arrives, and you should take
this opportunity to make a
note of it.  Since you have listed the properties, for
those who were buying stocks recently in June and May, as winter is coming, regarding the
seedlings,
yes.   They say it is sowing
seeds.  It's just like sowing seeds
.  Winter was just arriving, and on top of that, I had the
wrong timing to sow seeds for spring greens, lettuce, and chili peppers
.
You can view it that way.
And when
stock prices fall like this, there are
now too many stocks to profit from.   Even if you invest thinking of it as
six months of farming, it
seems like you can make a 30% profit here now. If it takes a year,
right? I
think a 30% return will come out when the price reaches this level.
Also,
stock volatility.  And in the
final panic phase discussing that volatility, there
were forced selling on margin, and
then at proprietary trading
desks and things like that—is
brokerage firm margin trading
still accurate these days?  It seems like they've mostly disappeared these days; I do
n't think I've heard of it recently.   That's right
.  yes.  Back in the day, the official in charge...
uh, that
Geojeogae... was that person Rulebreaker
?  You asked what a Brokerage is, and the
main tasks performed by a government official are three
things.  yes.  Eating trading commissions
.  But since they act as intermediaries for the sale,
it's a brokerage.  Next, the second is the acquisition
management role.  yes.  There is the issuance of new shares and corporate bonds, and the
third task is
proprietary trading dealing.
Dealing with the government's own funds—
this was 35 years ago,
um,
when viewed by an intermediate stock retrospective investor
.   This was
mentioned before, but the administration has now
increased its workload.   There is
also trust business and so
much more.  The role of Investman Bank has
increased,
so there used to be self-dealing, but it
seems like they aren't doing self-dealing these days.
Because as the retail market improved so much,
making huge profits from things like wrap products and whatnot,
currency exchange services also emerged.
Regarding the stock market.
So, these securities stocks have been steadily falling recently, haven't they? If
these securities stocks drop a bit, this
price level has already
become attractive. It is just that the entry point is now... well, you know how it shows up as
5.6 times over Kiwoom Jeong-myeong?  Right
?
When those stocks hit this September and October and turn around, they are
offering prices that are worth buying, and there are more than a few stocks I want to purchase
.
Okay, I'm going to take a look at the report. You've
brought a stock report today.
Ah, APR.
Let's look at the APR and Hynix APR reports first.
APR's stock price volatility has also increased quite a bit recently.
Uh, looking at the chart, APR
has dropped about 15% from its peak.  But
actually, if individual stocks only dropped 15%, it could be
considered quite strong, but let's take a look at the details first
.
Uh, that was researcher Han Yu-jeong's material.   This
is the earnings review material for the second quarter.  We projected consolidated revenue for the 26th quarter APR to be in the
750 billion range.   We
projected an operating profit of 180 billion won
.  So, the consensus profit is
167.4 billion, but it seems they
expect it to be slightly higher
.  The forecast is that while strong sales continued across all regions,
growth in the U.S. and Europe
appears to have been particularly prominent
.  Looking at comments from the U.S. side, it is
estimated that revenue will reach 353.4 billion, driven not only by strong sales on Amazon and TikTok but also by the smooth expansion of offline channels such as Target and Walmart.
Looking at new growth countries, sales in new growth countries overseas within the central region
amounted to 245.7 billion, so it seems to be doing well not only in the US but also in new growth countries
.
Even with the yy 208% increase table, it
was estimated to have increased by about 30%.   It is said that the
expansion of direct business in Europe, which began in earnest at the start of the year, is leading to better-than-expected results
.  However, looking at OPM,
we estimated it to be around 24.5%, but we expect it to have dropped by 1.3 percentage points year-on-year
.  It was also projected that it would have fallen by 1.2 percentage points in QQ
.  They stated that the transition is
estimated to have decreased slightly compared to the previous estimate, and that this is
judged to be due to the reflection of a larger-than-expected burden of logistics costs.   The
opinion is that it is time to focus on the scope of growth.  It is said that the burden of costs
in the second quarter was significant due to the expansion of air transport to respond to rapidly increasing demand while maritime transport lead times were delayed due to geopolitical risks.
However, the opinion is that we need to look at the
significance of external growth exceeding expectations rather than the temporary burden of costs
.   It is said that
in the United States, the transition to maritime transport is proceeding, centered around existing steady carriers
.  As the logistics system for production delivery
stabilizes, the proportion of transportation to Korea is
expected to gradually decrease.
Despite the burden of short-term financial strain, we expect operating profit to
hit a new all-time high every quarter.
As the supply chain progresses, the extent to which high sales
growth translates into increased profits will also
expand.  For investment purposes, I maintained a buy target
price of 500,000 won
.  Given that the absolute level of actual performance in the second quarter was
high, we judge that the
short-term burden on growth in the third quarter will be
increased compared to the previous quarter.  However, it is said that
during the first half of the year, the expansion of online and offline channels in the U.S.
and the results of initial penetration in Europe
were confirmed simultaneously.  New
SKUs and category expansions
are also proceeding smoothly.  Therefore,
based on the strong performance in the second quarter, the burden of short-term growth rates
may become somewhat prominent in the third quarter, but as the
results of regional channel expansion confirmed in the first half accumulate, there is a possibility that the
absolute profit margin of sales will rise once again in the fourth quarter, which is the peak season
.  It
seems like they talked about money in a positive way.  The current
stock price
is 380,000 won.  So, it seems they
suggested a target price of around 500,000 won
.
Looking at the earnings estimates below,
AP's performance is indeed so good that it's surprising every time I look at it
.  This year's
projected sales are expected to be 2.9 trillion won
.  It is divided into two categories: beauty devices and cosmetics
.
I think beauty devices aren't bad either.  As you can see, it is
estimated that approximately 313 billion won will come from beauty devices in 2024, 400 million won in 2025, and 550 billion won in 2026.  Well, in terms of
growth rate, it is not a bad
situation.  If we look at the cosmetics sector, it
is 339 billion in 2024, 1 trillion in 2025, and 2.3 trillion in 2026.  So, I think we can see that the growth of the cosmetics industry continues to be
surprisingly strong
.  Looking at the cosmetics sector, the Korean
side is actually seeing a decrease this year.  However, you
can see that while the US side was 480 billion last year, 1.2 trillion this year is coming from the US alone.  I think the growth in Japan is also very
good.  Growth in Japan is also coming out quite steeply, with 27 billion in 2024,
10 billion in 2025, and 157 billion this year
.  I didn't really know that the New Growth
Country was this good, but it was
94 billion in 2024, 350 billion last year, and
880 billion this year
.  So, it seems we can say that the cosmetics industry is
growing very rapidly
.
If you look at the operating profit margin, it
is at the bottom of the table on the right.  Uh, since we need to look at the
annual figures, if you go to the far right, the
operating profit margin is
estimated at 17% in 2022, 24% in 2025, and 25.1% for this year.  So, I think it is true that the rate of
increase in the operating profit margin has slowed down as well
.  When going from 24 to 25,
the proportion of exports
expanded so significantly that the margins
improved like that, and although they say it will come down a bit this year, the
level hit by about 1 percentage point will be
maintained anyway.  It seems like there are underlying estimates
.
It's a similar flow.  If you look closely,
when the proportion of exports explodes, the operating profit margin rises by about 4 or 5 percentage points, and
then an
upward trend of about 1 or 2 percentage points
appears only when the export sector continues to be strong but there is no longer any room for the proportion itself to increase further; it seems that AP is following a similar trend
.  So, since it is
currently trading at around 23 times its valuation, it is true that it is
cheap from the perspective of earnings growth or PG. However, if
the market values ​​the cosmetics or beauty device sectors highly, it is 30 times;
when the market is flat, it is 25 times; and
these days, when growth has slowed, it
seems to be viewed as low as around 15 times. But with an APR of
23 times,
considering the current market conditions, it
feels like it is neither expensive nor cheap.  hmm.   yes
.
But now the stock price itself is definitely
moving in a solid manner, so I
think it is one of the more stable sectors.
That is why I think it is the
strongest among consumer goods.   yes
.  yes.
There are many other things that have dropped by as much as 35% from their peaks, but the APR is staying
within that box range, right?
They said it was moving up and down, neither expensive nor cheap, but they are
n't giving us the opportunity to buy this good stock cheaply
.  Right?   If the price
dropped a little more from here, I would
buy it without any worries, but it isn't dropping.   If there
were 20, I could just buy them, but that's
not the case.   You know how when you
look at stocks like this after giving up, you get that feeling of, "Oh please, let a big correction
come so I can buy
."  Right?   The
operating profit margin was 17% last year,
23.9% this year, and is projected to reach 25% next year. If
you look at the sales revenue as well, it continues to
increase steadily; it is a remarkable company.   The
operating profit is 3 billion,
365 billion, and 740 billion.
Should I look at this in billions? Yes,
yes.  It is 1 billion.  hmm.
When I looked at Dr. Wang, he
's the same age as him. This
CEO was born in 1988.
Where does this APR's strength lie?
marketing.
Ah, marketing.   The
marketing effect was good, so we
maintained the plant image well.   hmm.
That is why it is doing well overseas
.  Well, since the
exchange rate is good these days, the environment
has been fully adjusted.  We can know about the goals conceded,
and the costs incurred in this quarter have
probably already
been fully absorbed.  Because there is almost no talk about Invi right now,
so the third phase
could become symptomatic, but if we
look at the sales figures, the second quarter was just 625 and the
third quarter was 619. We need to
carefully examine the growth and reduction aspects
.  I guess if you
reduce it like this, it's because the profit margin for the main store is
high.  If we reduce it like this,
there is a possibility that the profit margin could drop, but we need to see
how the situation develops.  Since the shipping industry could
perform well compared to actual market conditions, I
think it is not bad to carefully check the performance results.
Since MultiV isn't similar right now, I think Disk is historically
better.
Later, when you talk about the KOSDAQ, I’d like to ask about
Xiaomi. Mr. Yoon
Kyung-min asked a question about it. Yes, I am
watching Xiaomi, and you
mentioned that the price needs to turn downwards. Could you please provide a detailed
explanation?  You explained in detail that since Showmi's
business focuses on low-cost products, it is difficult to match
low product prices when terrain costs are high. Please let me
know later if you have any comments.
Now, let's move on to Hynix. Yes, this
is the BNK Immigration Service data.  Uh, as far as
I remember, Mr. Lee Min-yong was
one of the first analysts in Korea to reverse his stance on the semiconductor market.
Uh,
how many months has it been since you picked the flowers?   yes
.  If you look down to the right, the
rating was downgraded to hold on
April 27, 2026.  So
, uh, [snorting] at the time, the Knicks'
stock price was about 1.2 million won, 1.3 million won
.  Around April of this year.  yes.   He
reversed his opinion at this point, and although I am
not sure how things will turn out, if Hynix's
peak was around 2.98 million won, then it
can be seen that Lee Min-yu [Kotbangwi] lowered his opinion around the left waist level. Let's take a
look at the details.  That’s a bit of a conservative
comment.   The
opinion is that there is some momentum and we should wait for better investment opportunities.   It is said that the
possibility of adjusting the pace of AR infrastructure investment
has increased.  Server-sized
DRAM or ESST is still in short supply
.  However, it is said that the
economically competitive
infrastructure projection of hyperscalers providing orders is no longer valid
.  Meta recently
abandoned its frontier model and
turned its surplus infrastructure into external sales, and other CSPs
facing minor procurement difficulties and performance uncertainty are likely in a
similar situation
.  Currently, the consensus for US CSPs this year is an
83%
increase year-on-year.  It is said that next year is projected to increase by 23%, but
considering the expected rise in memory and CPU prices next year and the upgrade in specifications for new agent AI models, it appears that
at least a 30 to 40%
increase in capital investment will be necessary next year as well
.  However, the
opinion is that there is a slight discrepancy between current earnings forecasts for semiconductor companies and the likelihood of adjusting the pace of future investment.  So, regarding next year's earnings
estimates, it seems the opinion at UBS is that we should view the separate forecasts of 800 trillion
won for Electronics and 600 trillion won for Nippon's as
somewhat conservative
.   They say there are
concerns about the reason for this special AI cycle.  It is said that while
Taiwanese companies entered the DRAM market in large numbers in the past due to the digital bubble boom, it
now
appears that Chinese companies have entered the supply chains of major PC and mobile OEMs in earnest, driven by the AI ​​boom
.  In addition, since the
profitability gap among top memory competitors is no longer significant, we
predicted that the aftermath might be quite severe if the market enters a downcycle in the future
.  We maintained our hold on the investment and a target
price of 1.85 million won.
Cyclical stocks have a characteristic of
appearing undervalued as they approach the peak of the cycle
.  It is because performance rises steeply as it progresses into the latter half
.   It is said that stocks
turn into low PR stocks starting from the quarter where demand momentum slows. We assess that the recent sharp
decline in stock prices reflects slowing demand, and
earnings
momentum is also expected to decline after the end of the year, and valuations will no longer be cheap from next year onwards
.   It
is judged that it is not cheap.  Meanwhile, we
view the issuance of ADRs neutrally.
While it provides convenience for overseas local transactions, the valuation of the original shares will
not change.  It seems they are taking a conservative view on ADRs,
next year's earnings, and
Big Tech's AI
CAPEX investments for next year
.
It seems like it was presented practically as a short report.   If you
look at the earnings estimates below, they stand in stark contrast to the estimates from other analysts
for Electronics and Hynix that I showed you recently
.   It
seems like they are projecting next year's sales figures to be very low.  The estimate for this year is
343 trillion, and for next year it is 266 trillion.   We
also estimate that sales figures will drop significantly
.  The forecast is that this year's expected operating
profit will be 270 trillion won, but since it is projected to be 185 trillion won next year,
profits
are expected to plummet. Additionally, the operating profit margin is
projected to be 80% this year, but it is
estimated to drop sharply to 69% next year.
In fact, the land sector is
currently very short, but even the land
sector estimates that margins will drop by about 20 percentage points next year, so it
seems they are taking a very conservative stance.   yes
.  [Clears throat]
Honestly, when you look at it, being a semiconductor analyst in Korea is... well, because the market capitalization is
huge and it's the most important sector, there are a lot of them, they are the
most expensive, and it’s to the point where every
investment house can't function without one. But it does make me feel a bit
sad. It’s really
hard to predict the semiconductor market.  When
looking at these estimates, whether you
look at them in a separate way or a sorted way, the
truth is,
these karmic estimates have never actually been correct
.  yes.
Yes, because I have never been hit.  Everyone makes their own
estimations whenever they do this, but since my
estimates have rarely been correct, I always find myself
struggling like this every time I stir it
.  I feel a little wistful
.  But there’s no need to feel sorry for them.
Our fund managers who trade these kinds of stocks
are under a lot of stress too.
Right? It is difficult because we have to trade in a sector where
these estimates are unpredictable. But precisely
because it is difficult, if we can just
trade well on semiconductors—since it is a sector that everyone else finds difficult and even Charlie Man does
n't invest in—if
we do well, if we can handle this difficult situation—like
Kim Hyun-ah or Asamau's triple axe—even if
other players can't, if we can, we can
generate profits at the very top of the world. So we have to watch it closely.
Um, yes,
a basic
reporter brought one, and yesterday,
Judge Kim Dong-hoon from KB was basically saying, "
Don't trade blindly." He gave a report saying, "Don't
trade blindly."   Do not
waver.
yes.  Do not waver.  Do
n't do Buan-dong.
yes.   uh
.   I have
reviewed each of these different reports.   ruler.
Uh, I've
read the whole report.  Let's take a look at
how the US market turned out tonight
.
[Clears throat]
How does it turn out?   I
think it will rise tonight.
rising.   yes
.
Yesterday, the
decline
fell.   yes
.   Regarding the
SMP rate, the NASDAQ fell yesterday.
Our CEO, Choi Bu, said that Pilbeom is rising and I am too
.
Yes, it is professionally compatible.  [Laughs]
This time too, somehow, it dropped by about 15% and then
rebounded.  yes.
Strangely enough,
technically it was exactly a rebound point—
yes, even with all the
fuss about President Trump and all that—
I predicted it because I thought it was a spot for a rebound. But
what do you say is going to happen today?   I
think it will go up.
where?  Is it SP 500?
Uh yes, what is
it?  Is it Nasdaq or what?
Do I know SMP 500 SP 500?  Rise, rise,
rise scene, Jang
Pro,
rise, yes, Nasdaq rise. Uh, it was
falling yesterday, but why is it rising today?
What is the reason? Ah, because there were
issues with Iran and the US yesterday, even though there
was a rise in Lime and oil prices, it's a bit
[snorting]. Since the
US market
showed a rise in the Nasdaq yesterday, I
thought it might be a bit more sensitive to political issues. Password, Jeong, okay.
Nasdaq mode, rise.
How is the general situation?  I also think it's an increase. Yes, I
think the Meta News yesterday was very significant.  So, ultimately, as
Researcher Lee Min of DNK also assumes, the
possibility of adjusting the pace of infrastructure investment is
high. I believe that depending on how this assumption turns out, the
semiconductor sector, which is at the core of AI infrastructure,
could be significantly affected
.  In that respect, I think
that news from Meta yesterday may have somewhat relieved the long-standing concerns regarding this infrastructure
.  And
regarding Nvidia and Broadcom, the
semiconductor-related news from these companies also
looks somewhat positive.  So, I
thought there would be a bit of a lull until the hyperscalers release their earnings reports, but it
seems like Meta has broken that silence.  So I
think I can imagine.   yes
.
But on the other hand, I had a thought just a moment ago
.   yes
.
No, Meta...
since Meta and Microsoft released Chepy PT...
yes.  You know how you just went all out saying you would do something massive in the AI ​​field
.
yes.
But
in a way, have they shifted direction slightly?   I said I would do the
cloud.
Ah, Meta?
yes.
Uh, Meta didn't
really know that.
Ah, if Meta leveraged its own infrastructure to
improve profitability and productivity, did
n't it go on to expand from ad-up into cloud services?  The
companies that bought the most GPUs that were entering the market
were Meta and Micron in 2023 and 2024.
What did Meta do after buying the GPU
?
Uh, internal process.  So, what Meta
mainly does is
digital marketing, right?  Uh, in the end,
ah, yes.  In
the area of ​​target marketing on Facebook or Instagram, through
improvements in productivity and efficiency, as well as internal
reductions in labor costs, there was a
phenomenon where productivity and profitability improved quite rapidly for the first year or two, leading to a steep increase in the operating profit margin.  However, as the
current situation has slowed down a bit,
and as the
original strategy—that is, the plan to bring in expensive
personnel to drive new businesses—did
not work out well, I
think they are taking a proactive step by establishing a plan to convert a portion
of their data centers
to cloud business. They intend to
further promote the cloud business in these newly added data centers, rather than utilizing the surplus infrastructure
.   Is
there anything else you would like to add regarding the gift certificate?   It
seems that external sales of computers are actually being made, and
internally, we are continuously pursuing a high ownership rate. We are
currently preparing Super Intel Residence models, and when they are
released, models that can compete with the cutting-edge models,
although their performance will be slightly lower, are
scheduled to come out.   Regarding the
Super Intelligence Model, yes, we have just
developed an AI model.  is it so.  It is currently in the testing phase, and it
looks like it will be released in a few months.
It’s like something fun or a steel pit
.
yes.  Then, we are currently preparing an external model
So I was just going for it in that direction, but then I thought, 'Is
this not right? Let's just go with
the cloud.' I
suddenly got a bit confused as to if that was the concept
.   It
seems that Meta is following suit because Spec X demonstrated the potential of the cloud business.
Space X is an
example.  Ah, SpaceX is also a cloud service.
yes.  I have signed contracts for XI's u-cloud several
times, and with just that, it seems I am now at a
level where I can listen to BB
.
So that's why it's a bit confusing.
SpaceX did X AI, and in the meantime,
Google did it too. Companies like Jaminai and Entropy
jumped on the bandwagon, so
we viewed this as an AI infrastructure cycle.   yes
.   We used to just go all out
in that area, but what
Meta has announced now is
n't that we should go even further there; rather, since there is so much surplus
computing power, let's move some of that excess computing
power to the cloud.  Ah,
so I think it's going to be a two-track rack.
The AI ​​is gathered and sent out in this direction.  yes.
But regarding the massive spending on that side, the recently released Noiser was really going all out. As
I mentioned before, they really went all out,
but regarding the utilization of that GPU, it
needs to run at full capacity. Since it isn't running at full capacity,
aren't they diverting the leftover computing power to this?  And we did
put it back, but regarding the old,
outdated GPUs we used... well, they say we ran it, but even so, we have to keep
investing in this area. We should invest, and
move the surplus to the cloud. That works well, so
why
did they suddenly announce a data center in Canada?
So, as our department head said, "Let's
keep investing here, and since the cloud is good, let's
use the cloud too." That doesn't seem like the right concept.
What do you think of Meta's recent performance?
Ah, but I think I'm doing all three
.  We are investing to radically improve internal efficiency,
preparing new models for
sales, and
doing this for Cloudman
because Cloudman is currently in short
supply.
Disruptions keep occurring in entropy and things like that.
So, they are aggressively stating that they want about
double the volume but are only reaching 50%, and there is also a
situation where lag continues to occur in actual usage.  In the case of line models, for example
.  So it
seems like Meta is a tendency to add all three elements.
And regarding GPU utilization you mentioned, it's
not that the GPU can't be used because it can't be run, but because a
bottleneck occurs.
Even though the GPU is handling the final processing,
the memory, CPU, and networking
cannot keep up, so the GPU
is currently running at full capacity.  But that
means we aren't using our brains 100%
.  They say you can only use 10%
.  That is the big context.   There is
no route to output.
So, it is operating at full capacity, but only
within the acceptable limits of that situation. It would be
more accurate to describe this as the utilization rate, which is the current writing operation rate.   They say it is
about 30%.
To increase this, memory, CPU, and
networking must
be doubled or tripled to
meet the needs of the GPU, which is no longer running
.  So, realistically, the
GPUs are currently running at full capacity
.   As far as my
influence reaches.  So, the
reason the focus is now continuously shifting toward areas like burial and networking is that, while
GPUs are
expensive, it is
more cost-effective to expand the opposite side rather than just increasing the GPUs. That is the
overall direction we are taking
.  I think we can maximize performance by taking as much as possible from G-Field,
trying it out as much as we can, and
then upgrading the value chain to utilize it. By pursuing a
two-track approach, I
believe we can achieve maximum performance.
All right.   Now that you
mention Byeong-mun, I do understand a little
.
So, how did our market start?   yes
.  I started.  It started
up 3.31%.   It is
currently at 3.47%,
slightly expanding its upward trend
.   yes
.  It dropped so much yesterday that even though it
rose 3.5%, it
is still at 7,496.
What happened to KOSDAQ?   yes
.  The KOSDAQ started up 1.02%
.  Current Play.   It is
falling slightly.   yes
.  The rebound in the SSD is
not coming in as strongly as it did during the decline.   Right
?
So, how are Samsung Electronics and SK Hynix doing by stock
Yes, Samsung Electronics is rising in the 4% range
.  Hynix is ​​rising by 7.7% to 37%
.
And as for the other stocks, they are generally
flat right now, or trading stocks are
showing gains in the 1% range. I
think it will be around that level.
So, while reading the newspaper yesterday, I noticed that the
Hynix IPO subscription looks good. And
from the perspective of global funds that can invest in the US market but cannot in the Korean market, it seems they will definitely be coming in,
right?   yes
.   I
thought there would definitely be demand,
so when I heard that Hynix’s ADR was scheduled for today and tomorrow, I thought the
trend wouldn't be bad.
Now that the price has dropped to a sufficiently attractive level,
Hynix's strength could continue until tomorrow
.  And looking at the black market, if we
fully reflect that in advance, regarding the
bullish trend, the
main additional factor is
how much the memory market—including Micron, Hynix, and Samsung Electronics as a whole—continues to rebound.
Since the noise in the meta remains as a lingering afterimage, it
is not about overcoming this aspect, but in
the short term, it seems there is definitely some effect from the ADR listing
.   Well
, that's right.
What do you think will happen to the domestic market?   I'm
not sending Dr. Wang.
Ah, now it is a bit scary when Dr. Wang makes a bearish candle
.
Actually, if you look at it by sector, it's truly disastrous
.  That's right.  yes.  It is devastating, but since the
stock market is so ruthless,
forced selling begets more forced selling, and
that
pattern is likely to continue this morning as well.
What happens to the KOSPI?
Yesterday, I talked about beekeeping.   yes
.  I was a beekeeper, and a large bee appeared.
It was because the Bollinger level was broken yesterday.
So, the daily chart broke out of the box and came back up today.
Given that it received a massive shock this time, I expect to see some short
selling throughout the day, but I
think there is a higher possibility of a bullish candle today, even if just as a technical rebound.
Today is a
beekeeping day.  It was a bullish bee yesterday, but today is a
real bullish bee.
Today is real beekeeping.   Real
beekeeping.
All right.
Well, our Bonbetting has
posted another really great quote.   You
gave me Nemandela's famous quote.  I
never lose.  I either
win or love.
Mr. Cebu, yes. Uh, a
famous quote by Mansel Mandela.
Yes, I...
uh [laughter]... whatever you
said, I didn't quite hear you.   I absolutely never
read these books. I never fail
because I either win or I succeed.
So, if I take on a challenge and it goes
well, I'm a friend, but
if I fail, it means I learned from that failure.   hmm.
Exactly.  A truly great quote is "I
never lose."
yes.
In a way, you know how there are
many cases where you can't even attempt something because you're afraid of failing, even though you should be memorizing it.  yes.
So, actually, I have to
overcome that yesterday.
I had lunch with these two reporters, who seem to be in their 30s.
Yes.
yes.  And while doing so, we
talked a lot about this and that stock.  Because they
are government reporters.   We
talked about this and that, including
how to live life and things like that, and at the very end, we
talked about that.
yes.  I'm telling you.  When debating whether to open it or not,
go ahead.  Right?  Whether to go or not, just
go.
For example, if you don't go, you might regret it later and feel sorry, like going to a family event
.  I was debating whether or not to go to a wedding or funeral. We weren't
really close, but
we meet later anyway.  If I don't go, I'll be
sorry if we meet.  That's right.
But ah, I was debating whether to go or not, and you went for me.
Yeah, well, every time I meet him for the rest of my life, I
hear him say, "Oh, thank you for coming last time."
Then, even if you can't go, you
can just send 100,000 won.  If you just sent that 100,000 won, I would
n't feel sorry for the rest of my life, but you don't send it.
Then, the next time you run into each other, you might say things like, "Oh, I'm scared and
sorry,"
but ultimately, regarding the
action—I told you various things yesterday—
keeping and executing them is up to you
.   That's right
.  hmm.   It’s my
own responsibility, but looking back,
successful people didn't succeed without failure; rather, they
kept challenging themselves. You know, we’re like that too.
Well, Choi Bun-seong is like that, and
so are we.   You
keep trying and failing, trying and failing, and
then you just need to succeed once
.   Right
?  Once you succeed, it
seems like those who succeeded have done so without ever failing before, and as I mentioned, that was the case with
stock investing as well.  The common thread among those
around us who have seen over 50 billion won is that I
saw it at Banjia Banjia, and
Mapo Bridge once or twice. But I absolutely must not jump. I tell myself, "Should I jump or not?" I
absolutely must not jump.
Because you have to survive until the very end, yes, until the very end,
keep challenging yourself, fail, challenge yourself, fail, and then succeed just once. You just need to
succeed once. I mean, even if you fail, it's
not like Chairman Lee Byeong-jeok Seol is going to do it anyway. You have to come back empty-handed and fail anyway, right? Coming back empty-handed and losing everything you've earned so far—that is just not right.
So, the characteristic of people who continue to succeed is that they are
people who keep taking on challenges.   Oh my, Mr.
Ikkum, ah, Mr. Jeonmun, the old
sayings are so [laughs]. That's why you
absolutely must not jump off and keep going until the end. Anyway, yes,
try to see it through to the end. But those who don't take on the challenge, just like Alibaba's Majin
said, those who don't do it—the
lazy ones—
think more than scholars and professors
.  What are you thinking?   I have
no intention of doing it.
You are truly amazing for thinking so much about why this shouldn't be done.
What?  You try so many different things, do
n't you?
So, ah, looking back,
Father [laughs]
told me in 2007 to please stop Seigi from starting new projects. But what he was telling me to stop for
those 20 years
was investing in that Japanese restaurant
.   I
completely failed.
You lost an apartment in Gangbuk, didn't you?
[Laughs]
Anyway, there are many people who are upset about the stock market going up and down,
but you just need to
keep going. However, if you
look at the challenges, if you look at the practice sheets, it is true that there are
people practicing haphazardly
.
Yes, there are many nonsense ones.   The
one thing we
can confidently tell you is that if you consistently follow the Chesley Morning
Brief, you can definitely
become a player and
succeed in the stock market. Yes, that is
correct.  Let me tell you a funny story. You know,
I don't play golf
.  It’s not that I didn’t play golf originally; I actually played quite
hard at first, but the
pro at the driving range told me this.
Hey, try hitting a few truckloads of balls like that.   Is it
showing skill?  Oh, like that [laughs] kind of thing, right? Because it's so
nonsensical.
[Clears throat]
But, uh, no matter how hard I tried to fix it, it just would
n't get fixed.  I have my own reasons for not doing it,
so I decided not to do it at all.
[Laughs]
And you
have to do what you're good at.
yes.  Something you are good at.   hmm.
There are things you can do well in sports, too.
So, let's wrap
up by just listening to the bullish and bearish candles and Xiaomi's comments. The
key point of the Show Me the Money test is simply, in the end, the
GP margin rate.
The key point is how much GP margin can be achieved
.
During the last cycle, the
stock price started to rebound after almost passing through the ocean again.
So I have a lot of time.  Stock
prices aren't going to rise immediately, so for the major market, it might be okay to
check it once or twice before
entering. However,
looking at the current market conditions, I believe there is a possibility that we can exit with some GP margin in the second and third quarters
.
There is a possibility that it could go up again starting next year.  It was between 8% and
9% on
this day and last, but at that time, it was at a nearly
similar level.
Oh,
but you don't have an electric car.  I
have an electric car right now.  That's right.  that's right.   that's
right.  We have electric vehicles.
Electric vehicles are a business that can also benefit from the military's winning momentum, so they are
military vehicles.   It is
very good to drill a well in the long run.   In
the short term, for the exam, the buyer just needs to
buy the property on the inside,
so the person blowing the sound can
buy it.
Ah, so if you
think the price will keep going up, you should
n't buy it, right?  If you
buy that pair and look at it for
a year from now, I
think it would be okay to buy.  [Laughs]
Yes.  It's fine if you [clear your throat] in the long run
.  yes.  However, we need to hold out
well within this interspecies trading range.
Now, Mr. Bonnabe Team, I'll
send you one next time a good book comes out, so
no.  Please call me today.
Another good book arrived today
.  You
tossed in a comment every now and then, and I think it's really good
.
Yes, I will
send you a recently released book.
Chaeseul, that concludes today's Moni Brief for
Thursday, July 9th
.  Wait a minute, today is Thursday,
right?  Today is the day.   So, the
foreigners... they bet over 40 billion on put options yesterday, and it
ended up stopping.
Now, please manage the volatility at expiration today well
.   We
hope you have a happy and wise investment experience with Chaesli.  Thank you.
thank you